I think part of the problem
with the classical media,
let's say,
trying to make a transition to the
digital age is that they have no idea what
the digital media is.
Like.
I was watching an MSNBC,
a clip the other day about this robot.
I think her name is Sophia,
who,
who has a fairly advanced degree
of artificial intelligence
and who can manifest
pretty realistic human facial emotions.
And,
uh,
it was a four minute clip and add a
32nd ad at the beginning of it and you
couldn't skip the ad.
And I thought there's a real
arrogance on the part of the MBA,
ms NBC people to put that on youtube
because anybody who's familiar with the
youtube,
let's say,
culture knows that what you get to put
a ten second ad on and then you get to
skip it after five seconds if you want.
Like you can't ask people to pay 30
seconds of attention for four minutes of
content.
It violates the norms.
And so it had only had about 12,000 views.
And that's a really interesting example
of Marshall Mcluhan's idea that the
medium is the message,
right?
As you build a new
technological infrastructure.
And it's sort of like the old thing
because youtube is sort of like a TV
network,
but it's also not like
a TV network at all,
partly for example,
because when you put something on Youtube,
it's permanent.
And that's way different
than broadcast TV.
Like it's raw,
it's seriously revolutionarily different.
And so,
and it's also the case too,
that this is a strange thing and I don't
think the classic media understands
this either,
is that youtube people don't
like high production values.
In fact,
they're very cynical about them.
And I think that's because they've come
to identify advanced editing and Glitz
as markers that the information
is actually being manipulated,
which of course it is
now for better or worse.
I mean editing doesn't
have to be manipulating,
but it certainly can be.
And so,
and besides that,
a lot of the more tech savvy people that
watch youtube can duplicate those sort
of special effects in their
own home in half an hour.
So they're not there.
They're no longer markers of the kind
of competence and technological prowess
that would signal the sort of
competence that you could trust.
So,
so what youtube viewers seem to like is
basically ordinary people more or less
trying to have an intelligent
conversation about something confusing and
important and the attention span that
people are willing to devote to that is
actually quite remarkable for for a medium
that was nothing but cute cat videos
say five years ago.
The fact that like a lot of my lectures
and like Joe Rogan's podcast like three
hours long,
it's like what the hell?
People weren't supposed to have that
capacity to pay attention in this era of
fragmented attention.
You know,
in Rogan,
I don't know if you know this or not,
he has 120 million downloads a month now.
So that's 1.5 billion a year.
And so the last time I saw him,
and that was with Brett who just spoke,
um,
I,
I asked him what it was like to be the
most powerful interview or the world has
ever seen because I think he probably is,
if you think about it and sheer numbers.
I mean,
maybe Walter Cronkite back in the
60s had some comparable influence,
but he said,
I just don't think about it.
And we're like,
what,
what the hell is he
supposed to think about it?
Because no one knows
what to think about that.
And so he just has the conversations
and posts them and way he goes,
but he has no idea what role
he's currently playing in
society and we don't have
proper metrics for measuring it
and we don't understand it at all.
So anyways,
I did these big idea lectures with,
with Whoa deck and,
and uh,
they were ranked on,
on,
uh,
the Dvo channel and the five lectures or
six lectures I did all ended up in the
top 20,
which really surprised me.
But it was an indication that there was
something about what I was talking about
that for which there was a market.
And now there's,
there's some reasons for that.
I think,
you know,
when I.